good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight happy Friday there's so much
going on these days things are so crazy
but even some of us who are paid to
follow the news for a living forget to
stop every once in a while and ask the
most obvious questions and there are a
lot of them for example how did the
party that hates old straight white men
choose as its frontrunner
one of the oldest straightest whitest
men in American politics
its kind of remarkable it's baffling
actually Joe Biden who is that man must
be thinking the same thing holy smokes
how did this happen and what can I do
not to screw it up he's a lucky man and
he knows it
watching Biden you get the feeling he
doesn't really know what's going on
isn't know the answer to those questions
Biden is spry and energetic but he
really is from another generation he was
born a year-and-a-half before d-day if
elected he would be older on
inauguration day than our next oldest
President Ronald Reagan was when he left
office after two terms or put another
way Biden is old enough to be a OCS
great-grandfather
so when progressive radicals under 30
throw out some new ideological litmus
tests Joe Biden doesn't argue with them
he just agrees the latest test is about
abortion since 1976 a law called the
Hyde Amendment has prohibited the
federal government from paying for
abortions and for more than 40 years the
law has enjoyed strong popular support
overwhelming majority support including
from Joe Biden even people who call
themselves pro-choice understand that
it's wrong to use taxpayer dollars to
fund something as divisive as abortion
and yet a small group of progressive
activists disagree they know the core
political truth which is that repealing
the Hyde Amendment would amount to a
massive windfall of taxpayer money for
Planned Parenthood and Planned
Parenthood funds Democratic campaigns so
in the last year they successfully
bullied virtually every leading Democrat
in America into parroting their line
watch I will repeal the Hyde Amendment
it's the amendment in law that makes it
impossible for low-income women to
access the care they need the Hyde
Amendment is a directive
the black and brown communities like the
ones I've been representing if you visit
our website you'll see our commitment to
repealing the Hyde Amendment as
president I will make sure that we
repeal the Hyde Amendment I don't
support the Hyde Amendment and I will
lead the fight to have it overturn so
pause for a second throughout the
rhetoric and trying to think through the
reasoning Cory Booker's reasoning for
example if you can call it reasoning
he's saying that not using tax dollars
to prevent black and hispanic children
from being born is quote an assault on
black in Hispanic neighborhoods huh so
for the record this is true Cory Booker
has exactly the same position on
abortion as the Ku Klux Klan does Joe
Biden by contrast had different view
until last night at a speech in Atlanta
Biden announced that he's now in favor
of taxpayer-funded abortion watch for
many years as US Senator I have I've
supported the Hyde Amendment like many
many others have but circumstances have
changed and I've been struggling with
the problems that hide now presents I
can't justify leaving millions of women
without access to the care they need if
I believe health care is the right as I
do I can no longer support an amendment
that makes that right dependent on
someone Zipcar well that was a hostage
tape the circumstances have changed says
Joe Biden with circumstances let's be
specific
according to a report today in the
Atlantic Biden changed his mind after
his campaign took a call from Alyssa
Milano the left-wing actress and
professional unhappy person
if a Melissa Milano wants
taxpayer-funded abortion Joe Biden will
deliver it whatever it takes
does make you wonder though what
wouldn't Biden do what are his limits
is there any proposal Joe Biden wouldn't
get behind as long as it sounded new and
hip and progressive if for example the
woke community demanded a ban on
heterosexual marriage with Joe Biden
support that how about transgender
animal rights is he for those whatever
they are where's Joe Biden on a
testosterone tax to fight global warming
that sounds progressive very progressive
but
funded tampon dispensers in men's rooms
it would be transphobic to object now
for the record we made up most of those
issues they're not real but they sound
real it's 2019 soon they may be real so
we called over to the Biden campaign
today to see what the candidate stands
on all of those things they haven't
responded yet but if tomorrow morning
you wake up and read the Joe Biden has
endorsed transgender animal rights
you'll know he really does want to be
President either that or Alyssa Milano's
for him too